les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de Franz 24 en el sur de Francia
el festival de Kan continúa y con él el
desfile de las celebridades del cine
mundial en la icónica alfombra roja una
de las imágenes más fuertes que
guardaremos de esta edición número 76
será sin duda la del Trío de leyendas
del Séptimo arte estadounidense el
director Martínez Cortés acompañado de
los actores Leonardo DiCaprio y Robert
de Niro para el Western Killers of the
flayo sin embargo el ascenso por las
escaleras de la muy esperada película
asteroid City de wes Anderson no le
tenía nada que envidiar con su elenco
incomparable por su cantidad de rostros
y nombres conocidos dentro de los
actores más esperados este año estaban
también el británico y la sueca Alicia
vikander los protagonistas de Fire brent
del brasileño carimayús la película se
centra en Katherine Park la última
esposa de Enrique octavo interpretado
you love metamorfoseado en un rey celoso
y paranoico y para la cinta
es un dúo de actrices que iluminó el
festival de ghana a su llegada Natalie
portman y Julian Moore comparten cartel
en este drama que cuestiona la idílica
apariencia de una pareja que nació
dentro del escándalo en torno a una
relación prohibida entre un menor y una
adulta de al lado de los directores la
selección oficial tiene esta edición a
dos famosos italianos Nani moretí
presentó El Sol de la venida El Sol del
futuro en español una comedia situada en
la Roma de los años 50 mientras que
marco velozio conmocionó al público de
Cana con el Thriller rápido la historia
real del secuestro de un niño judío por
parte del papá pionoveno miremos unas
imágenes de la nueva obra de este Verano
del cine italiano
[Música]
liberaremos cuando
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a tu familia
dentro de la selección oficial otra
película marcó los Espíritus por la
fuerza de la historia real que cuenta se
llama las hijas de Alfa y fue dirigida
por la tunecina
una de las siete cineastas que compiten
este año para la palma de oro es un
largometraje que difumina los límites
entre ficción y documental sobre otra
tunecina olfano runni cuyas dos hijas
mayores y fueron para unirse al grupo
estado islámico línea sale periodista de
nuestro canal hermano en árabe se reunió
en can con la directora
[Música]
para empezar Cuál fue el detonante para
hacer esta película
fue en 2016 estaba escuchando un
programa de radio en el que invitaban a
olfa a hablar de sus hijas y el
personaje me pareció extraordinario en
cuanto a sus contradicciones en cuanto a
sus matices de gris Por así decirlo y a
los cineastas nos gustan mucho los
personajes claros y oscuros a la vez así
que me dije que me gustaría hacer una
película con ella y con esta Trágica
historia de estas niñas que me pareció
increíble porque representa todos los
temas que me interesan la adolescencia
la maternidad la transmisión de madre a
hija el trauma
y fue fácil convencerla sobre todo a sus
dos hijas
No fue fácil porque al principio ella
pensaba que yo era periodista así que me
costó un poco explicarle que iba a pasar
un poco más de tiempo con ella nos
conocimos en 2016 y rodamos la versión
final en 2021 así que trabajé en esta
película durante varios años
[Música]
hablemos de este dispositivo porque
decidió recrear los momentos más duros
de la película con actrices
profesionales
cuando se dio a conocer el caso todo lo
que me interesaba ya había sucedido era
el pasado así que era una cuestión de
recuerdos de Cómo volver a evocar los
recuerdos de forma cinematográfica y ahí
la ficción la ayudó mucho así que
recurría actrices y de día olfa y a sus
hijas que dirigieran a las actrices para
que reconvocaran estos recuerdos cree
una especie de dispositivo en el que
había un diálogo en el que
representábamos la escena pero también
reflexionábamos sobre la escena sobre la
naturaleza del recuerdo y su significado
que se hereda de una generación a otra
en su opinión esta película puede romper
este ciclo de violencia
creo que como la revolución ha afectado
a la vida de esta familia esta nueva
generación de niñas rechaza cualquier
autoridad maternal patriarcal
es lo que ella representa
pero como no tienen herramientas toman
decisiones morbosas a veces sin sentido
Pero al hacer esta película creía
entender Por qué
eligió la famosa actriz para interpretar
el papel de Alfa y crear este espejo con
ella
se pasa No es fácil para una actriz como
confiar en un director en un proyecto
tan híbrido donde incluso gente se
revela porque no es solo una película
sobre la vida de Alfa y sus hijas es
también una película sobre lo que es ser
actor como te enfrentas a un personaje
real
No yo no hago eso tienes que hacerlo así
la estaba dirigiendo Así que creo que
fue increíblemente valiente por su parte
haber participado en este juego en esta
Aventura
el cine tunecino vuelve a la competición
oficial tras 50 años de ausencia
que le parece esta elección del festival
de
en primer lugar estoy muy contenta mi
película fue la primera en ser elegida
para la competición por
ahora puedo decirlo porque lo ha dicho
él ya no es un secreto Así que fue un
golpe de efecto para Kan y eso es enorme
en fin felicidades y muchas gracias
el festival de cannesel lugar consagrado
para el preestreno mundial de películas
y a veces de series como es el caso este
año para Idol la atrevida nueva creación
de director de euforia esta serie de hbo
sigue a la superestrella Del Pop
jocelyna protagonizada por Lili Rose
Depp la hija de Johnny Depp ibanesa
paradi mientras navega por los bajos
fondos de la industria musical y que hay
bajo el hechizo de tedros un misterioso
propietario de club nocturno
interpretado por el cantante the weeknd
la revista Rolling Stone publicó una
investigación sobre un ambiente tóxico
durante la grabación y los mismos
creadores de la serie reivindican una
obra provocadora miremos el tráiler
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cada día centenares de personas buscan
obtener fotos y autógrafos con sus
ídolos al pasar por la alfombra roja
decana ciertos aficionados del cine se
destacan desde las alturas de sus
escaleras plegables Quiénes son estos
fieles del mayor evento de cine mundial
es lo que vamos a descubrir en el
siguiente reportaje
en el festival hay una tradición al pie
de la alfombra roja 150 cinéfilos se
sientan con sus escaleras plegables no
son fotógrafos ni paparazzi son
cazadores de estrellas es el temido
grupo de las escaleras plegables y la
batalla por tener la mejor vista ha
comenzado
deja de poner las escaleras no sirve
para nada un momento estamos poniendo
tablones
vamos a esperar vamos a esperar
en medio del caos algunas reglas se
mantienen
organización intentamos que haya cierto
organización desde los más pequeños
Hasta los más grandes así en escaleras
para que todos puedan disfrutar la vista
isabelones es miembro del grupo de las
escaleras plegables desde hace 17 años
toma fotos de las estrellas todos los
días y como resultado tiene una enorme
colección para mostrar
aquí
la foto es preciosa es de noche su cara
está radiante ella está siempre radiante
me encanta
para esta jubilada de burdeos esta
pasión tiene un coste 2500 euros por las
dos semanas del festival Pero estos
recuerdos en papel satinado no tienen
precio
es la alfombra roja es la belleza es la
maravilla somos como niños nos
maravillamos
Además de que su objetivo es
principalmente Johnny Depp
pero esa noche se convierte en un
fracaso Para Isabel
éramos demasiados allí Así que mi
autógrafos ni setas
pero para esta fanática No todo está
perdido hasta la clausura del festival
de Khan este sábado
Nos despedimos con otra estrella Pero
esta vez de la música El nigeriano
bernaboy dio un concierto privado en una
de las playas de can Gracias a ustedes
por su confianza y sigan con nosotros
hay más cultura en France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]